all right hot breath averse
welcome back to hot breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros
i am your host comedian joel byers and
what we are doing here at hot breath
is cultivating the next generation of
great comics
and our interview today is actually part
of our
journey to tracing the journey of
recording your own album
a member of the hot breath of her steve
rogers is actually
on his own personal endeavor to create
his own success
by creating his own album we've already
interviewed him once
in our podcast which is now also
available
everywhere you find hot breath and all
these q and a's
happen inside our facebook group so if
you're interested in leveling up your
comedy and you want to connect with
comics around the world and get involved
in future q and a's like this one with
steve
go join the facebook group it's linked
in the show description
and you will not be disappointed your
comedy will thank you
but without further ado thank you to
everyone tuning in live
and without further ado let's welcome
back to the hot breath of verse
the one and only steve rogers everyone
give steve some love here
give him hey man how are you let me see
if i can get a
sound effect going oh is it not
is is a sound effect going anyway oh
he's looking for the boo button i'm
sorry
what a great there's the applause okay
what a great start to this episode steve
welcome back buddy
hey man thanks for having me joel i
appreciate it
uh you were looking for the boo button
[Laughter]
took you a little bit
do the ooh button so it's good to have
you back here steve we had you on
a few uh a few weeks ago now maybe it
may have been like a
little over a month now uh yeah i think
a month or so
yeah and um when we first jumped into it
on our first episode it was more of kind
of like
getting the groundwork of hey i'm trying
to record an album
not even quite sure what i'm doing i
have some road gigs set up i'm going to
try to record it that's kind of where we
left off last time
right um no even plan about oh we're
gonna get on serious
maybe release it through this label it's
more like you're a comic
wanting to create their own album here
is me
jumping in head first and kind of
figuring out how to fly
as i fall you're kind of building the
wings as you fall out of the plane you
know which
i think is so important for so many
comics to understand
starting is the hardest part you don't
need to have all the answers
just start and you will figure it out on
the way down so i appreciate you being
so vulnerable
and transparent with sharing this
process with the
breathaverse happy to do so
uh it certainly has been a process
uh uh-huh i think the only thing that's
changed is i got a haircut
uh i think that's the only progress i've
made
um yeah my neighbor's car alarm's going
off so it really is
uh matching the tone
anytime i'm on a podcast it is it is
panicking um yeah i
i i um i've been on the road a few times
i was there a question before i start to
answer a question
um no no i mean people are people are
chiming in here
uh like yay steve rogers thanks for
doing this
people giving you applause and uh things
like that
um it's more of just kind of like where
we left off
where where are you now what is you had
some road gigs how did those
go and planning to record and like what
what's been going on with the process
so um it's obviously been very weird
uh i'm sure there are other people going
through this as
as well right right now as far as
deciding to do an album
during the pandemic um but all
it's hard for all of us right now uh
obviously
but um uh it's like a battle
you're battling the rust that you gained
at least i am from march to when i was
able to get back up again
which uh may have been may or june
and uh so it was a battle of that it was
a battle of
uh doing long the longest set i can get
in right now is at 20 minutes
uh when i get to open for uh brian
so it i realized um
trying to record an album which some
people have been able to pull off
during a feature set is way harder than
we think it is
uh because you know people that are
recording something they have
let's say two shows and it's an hour
long
and uh granted if you're the headliner
you could
just be flat out and i've heard stories
of this i've never seen
a live taping i've heard people go look
i got to do that joke again
i messed up that joke and this is my
last show that's being recorded
so there's a little bit of that i can't
do that as a feature one that's like
hey i'm secretly recording this even
though you guys don't know who i am
i'm gonna do that joke again you know
how i just earned your love and respect
i'm gonna put that to the test
uh five minutes in and uh so it's
it's very it's really uh um
i had to adopt the the mindset of
uh let's go and have the most fun i can
have on stage
and have it recording and if it happens
it happens if it doesn't
it's okay and that's very important the
most
i've learned so far is patience
[Music]
i did a and another thing is uh
venues you know acoustics are obviously
a very important
uh part of this and uh i did
the comedy act uh attic in bloomington
which is a
wonderful club amazing club i had great
shows
uh boy do i wish i knew how to use
equipment
uh no uh yeah they didn't record
um like i was the recorder i did not do
it
right so there's um
[Music]
no record of it uh of of shows that i
could have done it
um and you know you just have to let
that
water off a duck's back kind of thing
and uh
now i'm doing runs with brian where
it's a different show in a different
venue
and if you do get a recording of that
there is a sound difference
depending on the venue so if i perform
uh have you know a half hour in uh
in kentucky in a comedy club
their building is not the identical to
the one i just did in
in huntsville alabama so it's
if i were to put that together it's
clear to the audience
listening oh this is two different shows
why did it just drastically sound
different
and if a joke does great in one show and
and not so in another you can't
frankenstein
an album from two different venues
uh because it just the the sound's gonna
be horrible yeah so i've had
those are the things i've run into the
most uh as of right now
what what happened at the comedy attic
that
well one what um what were you using to
record with
at the comedy attic i have a
uh a zoom h6
and i have uh a comedian friend of mine
who records his own albums lent me his
um
his audience mics so i have uh
two audience mics that i plug into the
h6 which
is plugged into the microphone and
they're just set up in a way to
aim at the most people and and that's
another thing is where are they
they're obviously all six feet apart
from each other
so that's another thing is is
um you can still it can still sound
great but it's like how far apart are
they from each other
are if they're wearing masks that's
great health
wise but not great sound wise
uh think about that yeah so i really
uh picked a wonderful time to try and do
this
but i think i'm learning a lot which is
great
um yeah yeah so i'm i'm choosing to look
at the
uh the bright side of that but yes an h6
recorder
yeah and that i think we did break we
did go into the equipment uh
last time as well i do remember in more
detail but what is interesting now is
hearing you
we kind of this was before we put it
into action this was more of like here's
my game plan
i know i plugged the recorder into the
board and then plug these
mics into the recorder and it's gonna be
magic
then you get to the comedy attic great
show
it's all recorded and then you look and
you're like
oh wait did it not record did you like
not hit record or like what
i hit record it did not record the
audience mics
you know the most important sound on a
comedy album
uh i'd rather you hear the laughter
than me and unfortunately you could just
pick me up and and it's picking up from
the microphone not
you know it's not like when you record
on your phone where you can hear
everything
when you record on these different
tracks
the if it only records my mic you hardly
if at all hear laughter yep yep uh
so it sounds like me just pausing
and then starting up again so it sounds
horrible
as far as like you're missing half of an
album
and uh so that was very frustrating
especially when it's one of those shows
i had this moment which i'm sure you
experienced during yours i was like oh
this is it
this is this is the one i i'm
just stay in this moment don't overthink
you have
you're you're having a ball they're
having a ball
this is this is definitely the recording
and
and then you don't have it um
but you know you you learn from
failure and and certainly our business
involves a lot of of that so that's uh
what's happening
did is bro was bryan aware that you're
recording and that
there was a mishap did you have any
words of encouragement
uh brian is very encouraging um
i've had these audience mics set up in a
way where
my i mentioned this before i believe
um when you're you know i'm the feature
i'm the opener
uh he comes first uh headliner comes
first
like uh if uh
so equipment can't be in his way um
if he doesn't want me to record i don't
record he thankfully he's the most
generous person in the world so he was
totally fine with it but you know make
sure the equipment's not in the way well
i've had these
audience mics hidden so sometimes he
doesn't even know that i'm trying
on a show and uh one show
recently i had to have the audience mics
a little further up
so they were obviously visible to him
and he didn't know what they were he
never had noticed them before
so during his set he started making fun
of the audience mics
not knowing that they were and i had
said to
uh the host who um is my girlfriend i
was like should i
move the mics like uh you think he's
gonna notice that
i don't wanna cause any problems she's
like no it's gonna be fine and he spent
like three minutes making fun of
whoever put those there not knowing it
was me
uh so other than that it's been pretty
great but that moment it was
uh it's difficult but uh
he's very encouraging he's recording his
netflix special um this month
oh wow and yeah uh in an outdoor
uh theater and i've been watching him
himself prepare for a recording and
that's been uh
very encouraging and comforting just
seeing
oh this guy is playing with things and
he's uh
working it out and you can play with
something until the last minute which we
discussed before and it was so that's
been the most hope is watching him get
ready for a recording
and uh seeing someone who's done it so
many times
uh and you're doing it your first time
it it really
lowers the um anxiety levels
that's pretty serendipitous too that
you're both working on
recording something at the same time
that's pretty cool right
yeah it's been great so you've you've
tried to record a
few times then at a few different shows
and it hasn't quite
just happened no it's like
um i have like
some i i could have some tracks that i
could send to sirius
like i i'm uh i know that i could send
that
and it would do well and everything but
uh
i am a little bit of a perfectionist and
i i kind of just
also i'm a comedy nerd so it's like no i
want to really i don't want to release
an ep i want to release an album
you know like an ep is good i know a lot
of people that have released those
20-minute
ones that are really good but
and i'll probably have to settle at some
point if i can't get it
but uh i would i'd like to release a
whole thing and and
i just haven't had that um all the stars
aligned yet
either one thing went wrong here or one
thing went wrong there
and that's me just learning the
equipment and
it's it the thing i didn't put into
account
is when you produce your own album and
record
record it yourself is those
when you do it with a label or anything
they're setting it up you don't have to
think about it
you just go up there and you just do
your set
and uh i'm no i'm the guy that's
that's running cords through things and
tying things to this and then all of a
sudden i'm running up on stage
uh which can make you not in your head
about uh
your set until you get up there then
you're like oh my god i haven't thought
about
jokes until i grab the microphone
so it is um i am learning that kind of
thing and why
labels uh deserve some way more credit
than i probably gave them last time
uh but that is also yeah some i think
comics to think about is like
because i did before i recorded my
special and realized it was a special
not an album i did
try like a few diy recordings
where i plugged it into the board um
at one show i um there were the host was
on stage and i was still trying to get
all my equipment together
and i thought that i could quickly
i've somehow thought i could quickly
enough while the host is performing
plug in the recorder the uh the sound
goes off
this is a sold out show oh my sound on
the mic goes off
for like five seconds is i'm like oh
that was me
and then i had to like fix it really
quick but that was me
that diy of like yeah i'll just plug it
in real quick
but that's what you're saying there's a
big distraction i was about to go on
stage which is why i was scrambling so
there is a value
to having someone that
audio is their job right to hire them to
do it
or if you have a friend that has done it
before
and write them to the show to help you
out like
for the comedy special taping what i
ended up doing i had an audio
guy and i had video like i was like the
video guy was like yeah i can do both i
was like
let's not even risk you're the video guy
here's the audio guy you both just focus
on what you need to do
and then we can bring them together and
that that really
alleviate a lot of stress for everyone
of just like this is your job this is
your job this is my job
let's everyone do their jobs and we'll
have a great success here
uh a hundred percent agree um i think
the only thing that stopped me from
doing that is they're not my shows you
know like
um another just respect to the headliner
i'm not going to bring a a film guy or
an
audio guide to mess with a thing
um makes perfect sense and and
and that's the the other added
trickiness level right now is
is with the the pandemic like no one
knows
who i am understandably and it's like
i'm not gonna be headlining anywhere
anytime soon and and some places aren't
safe to headline yet
even if they are willing to have me
but um so it's like it's
mainly just featuring for brian is the
only road work i'm i'm
getting that i can you know thankfully
make enough money to do it all and come
back and
and not be in in the red um
so that's just another added hardness to
it
is it's just these 20-minute sets and
hoping
you're just trying to get lightning in a
bottle is what it is
more so than it already is recording an
album
so it's been uh but i've learned a lot
about patients and
and the longer you
i've always said this to myself the
longer i have to wait the better i'm
getting
yes um uh
so it's like by the time i do it
i'll be the best i've been
so i might as well get better on the way
to whenever this recording
is exactly and focusing on what you can
control which is just making it the best
show possible
yes yes radical acceptance i love it
yes radical acceptance we learned that
yes before the show you taught me that i
love that
i love it uh focus on what you can
control which is the material so
i have over here i have posted notes
all over the place can you see
him can you yeah i mean let me see if i
can oh no
we're making steve uncomfortable this is
great no you're fine no it's um
it's you're uh i'm gonna be moving with
the
i don't know how to use oh god see i
already did it great
and this is something um we did a q a
with mike vekione
and he showed us his like poster board
that he had on his wall with all the
different like sticky notes and ideas he
has
um people love seeing that stuff
oh god oh oh i accidentally
unplugged you sound great though okay
great
i'll show you then yay we're going in
deep here hot breath the verse
and if you're listening to the podcast
version go on youtube and you'll be able
to see
his uh sticky notes as well in that
whole process
all right whoa so yes so right
here oh god this is like this is like my
dad facetiming
um okay right here
oh this is so cool and you're going for
and this is just as we're transitioning
morris is asking how many how long are
you planning the album to be in like
how many uh bits are you planning to do
and maybe that can parlay into the
sticky notes here
yeah i'm hoping to do like 45 to 50.
okay um or really it's like
don't i'm not gonna pick a time i'm
gonna
i'm gonna pick the jokes that are good
so it's like i hope it's 45 to 50 but is
it
good is it like if it's not good then
it's 38
you know so whatever is good
um and then
they're sort of color-coded but uh
this is oh let me let me bring you up
full screen actually so we can
oh wait ah ah
i'm gonna switch real quick everyone
because i want you all to be able to see
um steve's
um
i wonder well there you go joel never
mind
i don't know what i'm doing well i mean
this is
basically an episode about how we don't
know what we're doing
i i unplugged the equipment that now you
know that i definitely didn't it is
because
i didn't record it right because i just
undid all the equipment
to come over here by accident and then
no one is judging you for not getting in
full screen
beautiful okay so did you what do we
what what would you like for me um what
yeah so what's going on here with the
color coding um yeah how is this
organized
how are you kind of planning the set so
this uh
the beauty of like a bunch of people do
post-it notes this is not
a me thing um and i
the reason i did it was it's like uh
when you do it on a spreadsheet or like
a
a word doc you you can't phys
like you can delete and you can
move around and you can keep editing it
but like
when it's on a sticky note it's physical
it's
it's done and you know it's an ink
there's nothing more to be done to it
except throw it out
um so that was my reasoning on that as i
could move
like this maybe this shouldn't go here
and now i'll just pick it up and put it
over here
so it's like seeing how they connect and
where i can physically move it is
helpful
to me um and then
uh the color coding is letting me
realize what they're about
like uh pink is is uh dating in
relationships because i'm really
original
and um i picked pink for girls
and the green
is two different topics it's um i
realize a huge
portion of it is body and mind
i have a lot about um working out and
physicality and then um a lot about
anxiety and
and mental health so it's like those
sort of go together so there's body and
there's mine
uh blue is look at that right there i
got it right
i got it perfectly um blue is uh my
parents
and then uh purple is is stuff that's
like
um it's a mix of things that aren't
a huge theme so it's like uh
there's a captain america joke in there
there's um
a fly a couple flying uh bus and
um i'm a big fan of classic rock so
there's that so it's like stuff that
isn't as
big of a theme mm-hmm and is it
organized in order
like on your wall is this like beginning
to end is left to right
um this is was made yesterday
uh so right now it's what i think is the
order
great um but it's going to be looked at
in more detail
uh this week because i'm doing
a run-through of it uh and i wanna
i wanna treat the run-through as if it
is the recording
um and and no uh
fallbacks like oh well i didn't figure
out the order yet or that kind of thing
i'm trying to treat it as a real
uh thing so i'm working on it yeah and
on the sticky notes is it just kind of
like
uh like the headline of the joke or is
it the actual joke written out
it's uh just the headline um
so now for the dating i noticed
like this one
is mostly about me it's like a fight we
got into
or uh how i am with woods girls or
one story that was a problem
between me and my girlfriend and then
here's like uh what she's like
and then here's uh arguments
and then here's like break up with my ex
kind of thing
very cool so it's like
i noticed the anxieties about me the
stuff about exercising bodies about me
um you know you it's
mostly about me and so like the dating
one was difficult
because i have stuff that describes a
lot of stuff that describes her
but i'm like what jokes do i have that
teach you what i am
i'm like in a relationship because these
jokes teach you what i'm like mentally
these jokes teach you
what i'm like in a physical experience
uh you learn about me through my parents
what are you learning about me through
my girlfriend so it's like
difficult because i'm describing who i'm
with but also i want to show you what
i'm like
in a relationship it's hard to i like my
girlfriend i'm not one of those guys
that's like
making fun of their their spouse so it's
like
one of those things um so it's just
trying to figure out the right order so
it's like
well you just did a joke about what
you're like in an argument with your
girlfriend but now you're talking about
your
your ex and now you're talking about
first dates and now you're back to
arguments again
so it's just making sure that um the
transitions make sense
so there's not whiplash in a
dope kind of thing and then it's also
seeing if
it's like i have one joke about getting
an mri but i have
nothing about going to the doctor
or anything like that so it's like well
obviously this joke's gonna sit out
and be on the next thing um oh my gosh
yeah it's doing the the topics justice
like this one right here
i used to work at a grocery store i used
to be a lifeguard
mri there's only three
jokes and grocery store and lifeguarding
but it took up years of my life so it's
like
let's do the material justice and wait
um because clearly i'm not done
on that i know i'm overthinking but it's
like i don't want to
come to a second album and be like hey
here's the uh
the the rest of that trunk
[Laughter]
three years later exactly
uh that's my thinking process that's
such a good process too of thinking
about
what is the audience learning about me
through
each of these topics that's such a great
kind of filter to help personalize all
of your jokes
yeah i don't want to um somebody gave me
a very nice compliment when i
started uh which was like there
they said uh it felt like a
i felt like steven's friend and i have
never met the guy wow
and uh i was like oh okay so that's what
i'm
gonna do i like that i like
being the i mean this is an introduction
to
me but um i want it to be personal
enough where
you hear me down the line you're like
well i know what this guy's like
so if i ever talk about a broader topic
like outer space or something
they know who i am first yes
um also i i'm a narcissist so of course
i'm going to talk about myself
but it's important because that's the
same thing nate bargatzi said
was that like he he puts the jokes
through him he can have a joke about his
wife
but she isn't the butt of the joke it's
him that is the joke and that was a big
shift in his
perspective of his writing was oh people
laugh
people get a little uncomfortable if i'm
pointing and making a joke of my wife
but if i talk about my wife
through me then that's when the joke
becomes funny
yeah i would say i'm very similar
there's maybe a few times where it the
punchline isn't me
[Music]
and uh it just seems to be how i
am uh but uh yeah i think it
it endears you i don't want to come off
you know you still want the audience to
root for you so you don't want to come
off
like helpless and pathetic or
you know a jerk so it's like figuring
that out
but um yeah and i want you to know about
the people i care about so like if you
learn
oh he he loves his parents uh
but here's what drives him nuts about
his his parents
but it's still on me like here's the
chaos i went through
when my dad got hacked on facebook or
blah blah blah like
my mom kind of thing um
so it's like important that you learn
about me because it is an album where
it's like this is like the pitch of do
you want to
follow me as a comedian it's like the
first album
is how i'm saying it yeah it's a very
exciting time for you
and how um uh morris says first album
stephen sounds like my friend that's the
new
that's gonna be the album title oh
that's not bad
what and how long have you been doing
comedy again just for people who don't
uh seven years i think it would be eight
in january eight in january very nice
yeah that's great and um yeah we do have
a few questions coming in here
here um uh
john asks is ten minute ten minutes of
material good for me to record an
album um
that's funny i don't know if it's um
that could be an ep
i think i don't know what the standard
is on an ep like how long they're
usually if it's always 20 minutes
or um i'm i'm going back to let's see
how good i am yeah
yeah go ahead and um i've yeah i've had
friends who have recorded
like like a 20 minute album or something
like that so that it wasn't a full
length
oh boy where'd we go where did we go
oh i'm still here right you're still
here
oh god it was the same time i turned on
the recorder and i was like is this
thing
is it is i shouldn't touch anything
no you're great what's happening oh my
god
hold on we're back wait we're about to
be back
kaboom that's so funny that uh
this is see this is everyone this is the
diy approach to recording an album and
podcasting
oh man making comedy but see what's so
fun is like these are going to be the
moments of like do you remember when
joel byers were doing this stupid q a
and they couldn't figure out audio or
video yeah
i mean i didn't think it was stupid
until you said it now i'm uh
now i know how you feel about it
uh i was wondering why you kept looking
at your wrist um
it's not stupid we're making history
right now i know exactly
the creative process like never before
so it's not stupid
if anything it's revolutionary which
people sometimes
find a stupid stupid because it's just
unfamiliar to them
but what we're doing is truly
groundbreaking steve so i'm thank you
for
recalibrating my mindset around it no no
no when it comes to me i'm definitely
more stupid than groundbreaking
so you had it right the first time
now we're trying to out deprecate each
other
[Laughter]
this is like watching two nice guys
trying to figure out
how to get through a conversation
um the ten minute thing i think you
could
like i i i truly don't think there's
anything
like it's almost like right now it's and
you're an example is like
anybody can do anything during the
pandemic just
it's like what you can do it's just like
for me is am i going to be proud of it
um
and i'm a little bit of a like uh like i
said before a nerd
i wanted to be a full thing
so i can i've talked to brian uh about
this
he gets excited about uh releasing the
thing and then
slowly getting rid of it so he can work
on and play
for with a new hour and it's like i'm
i feel like i'm ready for my first time
playing with an
with an idea of a new album yeah
and uh if you want to do that that with
10 minutes
no one's stopping you you know yep and
no one's saying get rid of it but i
i just see the the person i
you know he's an example so is bargetse
of someone i would like to
be like as far as what they're doing and
uh so i'm trying to do the same thing
yeah so yeah it's important yeah we're
not saying don't do the 10 minutes but i
think two things steve has said in this
interview is
one the number one thing he's learned is
patience throughout this process
and also two it's like you just want to
you want to be something you're proud of
so if you've been doing comedy a year or
two years i mean i'm not gonna say don't
but i will say probably by year four
you're gonna be like
what was that and why did i say any of
it
right so it is also like kind of one
thing at a time
and just honing the craft you know i
didn't record anything until 10 years
and
steve is seven almost eight years in and
he's recording something
because we hit moments where like okay
i'm proud of this this is something i'm
happy to put out and live on forever
right
and with the rate i learn technology
i'll be 10 years in
when i record it so it works
another thing about the the patients
before we get into the next one
um i was you know
uh whoever you're with is always your
rock and i was talking to my
girlfriend about how i want to record
this thing
and getting really uh worried that it
won't
happen before we whatever comes next the
winner is gonna be harder to do more
shows
because of the times we're in but uh she
was like what was the what's the rush
you're just gonna get better and that's
kind of
what i said before like but she's truly
made me realize that is like
uh you don't complain about how
uh you ha you don't have it yet because
it's like all that energy could be used
to look at a chunk that you're like well
this is as good as i
can get it right now well you have time
to make it better you have time
to to play with something uh
and make it uh even one percent better
before you record
so that's the mindset i'm choosing yes
beautiful mindset
and another question is
um amanda's asking
have you thought about what city you
want to record the album in
um that's a good question like i said i
don't think anyone
no one knows who i am so i don't have uh
any uh name steak or whatever the word
would be
but um see i think the first one you
you're gonna have to accept that there's
probably gonna be a lot of people that
know you personally
in in in the audience um i don't know
what your ex
experience was but like um so it might
be here in new york
uh in new york city or
i'm from upstate new york maybe it will
be in syracuse
where i'm from or buffalo
or rochester where i start you know was
working a lot as i was growing uh but
probably here in
in new york with the way things are um
is my guess but i want it to be people
that know
my sense of humor and already like me so
that it's a little easier
to um start over if i mess up on a joke
and it's the last show
and the last chance or that kind of
thing so with people
and in a place you're comfortable i
heard uh anthony devito who's a
wonderful comic
say once record it in a place that means
something to you
and uh that's that's definitely my goal
is to do it in a place that
i care about and i want to do well in
yeah that helps get the jitters out too
i mean mine
i recorded mine in the first venue that
ever headlined me
it was a nice intimate black box theater
called the basement theater
and it was you know here in atlanta
where i started so i was able to sell it
out
with friends and family and students and
things like that
so uh yeah it was it is kind of like a
nice kind of victory lap of like i've
done all this work
now let me just present it to people
that are like have been supportive of
this journey i feel like that's a very
valuable way to
be comfortable in that seemingly
uncomfortable situation
agreed yeah yeah good question amanda
angela is asking how long
will the edited recording be
uh kind of like i i said before angela
if you weren't listening geez
she actually loved the sticky notes she
said wow this is great while we were
over by the sticky notes but maybe she
missed oh
cool um i it looks like a
a passive aggressive roommate just
telling me to it's like laundry laundry
laundry laundry
um oh it looks awesome i'm very
impressed with how clean your place is
as well
because most comics would be like well
let me move the dead body out of the
floor and i'll
run over to my sticky notes you you know
i've learned a lot of
you know when you get stuck in your
apartment for uh six months you're like
i might as well make it livable
uh yeah cluttered space cluttered you
know exactly
um i don't know how long it's gonna be i
like i said before i
i hope 45 to 50 i would like
you know that's a uh not too long i
don't want i don't know if i could do it
an hour and and justify having people
listen to me for an hour
um in my head so i'd say 45 to 50 is my
goal
but like i said before i want it to be
great i don't want any so
so things in there and being ocd about
the time
so if it's like 38 minutes is
is the is the killer stuff then it's a
38 minute album but i'm hoping
45 to 50 is the goal
pretty nice uh morris asked will this be
on
vinyl oh man i mean
i'm a huge huge rock fan
and i have a record player and i'm very
like stones alice cooper these kinds of
guys
um i don't know if i could ever put
myself on that level
so um i think that'd be really cool
but um i don't know if i could uh
i i'd have to really be consider like
someone uh
talked me into it but that would be
really cool i don't know
yeah that's i think that's why i love
documenting this process with you
steve because it is you you don't have
all the answers like
yeah you're a comic who has who has an
idea
hey i want to record an album okay how
do i do that well my friend's done it he
has equipment
yeah i'll just plug in the equipment on
the road and then magic and then you're
like oh well that didn't
work okay let's revisit the drawing
board what's next like you're
you're learning as you go and i think
that's so valuable for comics to
understand
of that process of yeah you're you're
figuring out as we go along you don't
know how you're going to release it you
don't know where you want to release it
you maybe want to record it here like
it's all
just i have an idea here is me putting
that idea into action which
is the hardest part in a lot of comics
we can overthink
or self-doubt around who am i to do x y
and z
but i think you taking action and being
just honest about
i don't really know yet i think that
that's helping a lot of comics along the
way
wow thank you that's the first time that
uh my lack of knowledge has
led to a compliment so i really uh
appreciate it
i will i will say this uh we you and i
definitely touched on this last time but
uh
while we're at it i don't have a manager
or an agent or anything like that like
all this is is um
is just because i want to do it i don't
i
i'm one of those guys where uh i'm
thankful i get up
a lot but i'm not a hot commodity like
no one
my inbox isn't being blown up i'm not
one of the guys
so it's like i can't wait i don't know
if that's ever going to happen
so i'm just going to do it because i
want to do it i think that's important
is um not getting mad that i'm not
bigger or more popular and it's just
like well putting in the work
that someone that is should
so that's why i'm doing it myself
uh and that's i i you know
don't uh don't try to be big do the work
a big person would do
is what i'm trying to do boom and that
that was my mindset around
uh me recording like 10 years into
comedy was like
okay i've been doing this almost 10
years what am i trying to achieve in
comedy
it's like i want to be a great comic and
it was well what do great comics have
well they have an album and then the
album just organically grew into a
special
when a fan of the podcast was like hey i
have a video production crew let's just
record this
right that just all happened organically
but it was first like
well who do what do i want to do in
comedy okay well what does that level of
comedian do
they have an album okay let's do it kind
of like you're saying
you're almost like living into your
future successful self
yes that's the hope yeah that's
we are we are doing my friend
um and speaking of future successful
self i think we did touch on this
theodore is asking how you got linked up
with uh brian regan
um yeah i'll briefly just say
everything i've gotten i've gotten by
people seeing me live
um and uh you know
the the late night credit i have and
brian
and uh most work there's just someone
that saw me and
thought i was funny and um
you hear that about a lot of people like
uh i think
bargettes he got fallen because fawn was
in the audience
so it's uh i think that's a good way to
also
get over a hump of uh of taking
stand up for granted too is just pretend
that this is an audition
if that's what you have to have the fire
under your
your belly or whatever um so i got lucky
that
i was just having fun on stage and doing
what i loved to do and
someone important uh was in the audience
and changed my life
so uh just from performing
yep and i can say with us doing almost
300 interviews that's
a very common thread with the most
successful comics we've seen
is their either advice or their own
experience has been
i was just funny on stage and the
opportunity happened
you know so that's why it is so
important just focus on
getting funny first and a lot of your
opportunities will just come from that
yeah i'm pretty sure that's like how
michael che got snl
it's like a lot of people uh that
probably people that you look up to now
got to where they are
because of that so it's a common thing
and it makes sense
yeah for sure uh let's
let's do two more here kiddos um
greg brown asks does recording and
listening to your attempts
teach you anything about your delivery
tone tempo that you didn't know
yeah i i would say so um
sometimes it's uh mistaking
uh talking too fast for energy
uh i um what do you mean by that
like um
sometimes i i i
[Music]
will talk very fast uh when it's a thing
that gets me excited like
agitated or whatever and it's like um
not everybody uh processes how fast
uh i you can speak you know it's like
every any most times it's like i guess
trying to remember the emotion i i'm
uh trying to express but
it's important that they know what i'm
saying and uh
sometimes if it's an anger joke i can
talk very fast
uh in the hopes of them realizing this
is coming from an angry place
yeah and then i trip and then i stutter
and then
the joke can be flubbed um
so it's uh how are other ways i can show
how i feel in this joke and that kind of
thing also um volume
and and silence i'm trying like i'm a
big
gary chandling fan and he says the truth
is in the silence and a lot of people
have said that about stand up um
so pausing is uh i've noticed that oh
i i have a joke right now
where uh i i used to be a people say
swimming is not a sport and i know
i don't think it is because when i was
in high school if
you were in a sport you could give your
jersey to your girlfriend
to wear and that would get a
when i paused they would get a laugh
because they remember oh he's a swimmer
he couldn't do that
because that's a speedo and that's not
even what my punch line
is but when i say it slower
they i get an extra laugh because when i
pause that i get a laugh because they're
like oh my god you're right you couldn't
do that
it's a thing that no one ever thought uh
in the audience
so i give them that chance to realize
that before i get to the punchline i'm
actually going to
beautiful yeah you can learn a lot about
delivery from listening back to your
sets
yeah and it's excruciating at first but
then
uh you can get numb to it
and it's very helpful and it's part of
that of
okay what kind of comic do i want to be
well
the great comics are reviewing and
learning and refining their sets i mean
i remember hearing
when uh joe rogan did a show in texas
earlier this year
like during like it was his first set in
a long time since quarantine and he was
like oh yeah like leading up to it i was
like listening to old sets i was going
through my notebooks like
someone at his level was like listening
to stuff refining like okay what do i
have here what is my material so
yeah if you want to be a great comic it
is doing those habits of great comics
now that'll then
propel you into that great comic status
exactly it uh it's not stuff you do once
you become great
it's stuff you do on you know what i
mean
it's like they have to keep doing
it or they won't be great anymore and
that's how they got there it's like
that's the ingredient
obviously their talent but like of
course that's important but the work
yeah and um yeah the final one here
let's
go to i'm re and i think this will also
steve segway into your
show this weekend but um uh imri is
asking
zoom mics yay or nay
zoom mics i love zoom mics um
i think um that
uh they're very helpful i think um
it's a safe place to try new
you're in your own home uh if you don't
have the comfort
to take a risk sitting in the most
comfortable place
and to you i don't know
at some point you just have to take
risks and i think it's easier to do it
from your chair
so i've done a lot of them i like them
it's nice for tweaks
and also people are locked in it's
uh i find people are more generous at a
i've done a lot of the ones
that you guys put on uh because it's
it's uh people are more it seems like
we're more likely to watch the comedian
here whereas a mic uh outdoors
or well now it's outdoors but the mics
used to be
people on their phone are looking at
their notes but right now it's like oh
there's only five of us
i can give you all the 20 minutes of my
time
and then do the five that i have
prepared
yeah exactly yeah i agree there yeah zoo
mics you get a lot of great feedback
for sure so i think they're worthwhile
for sure
and um speaking of as we land this plane
you are doing a zoom show yes
correct i am i'm uh this saturday i'm
gonna be doing
uh a run through of the album i'm not
recording
the album on zoom uh but uh i'm gonna
run the material
uh on the actual date i was supposed to
record
before the pandemic hit
uh yeah it's just like well i gave
myself this date i'm still gonna stick
to the date
that i gave myself um and uh run the
material and
and uh i've got a couple friends that
are gonna do
some short sets but it's mainly just
me running the album um and seeing
doing a long set for the first time in a
while and seeing how it flows and
if i'm on the right track beautiful
yeah so definitely um share the link and
i want to um i'm going to go ahead and
post this i was going to save it
for later but i do um i'd like to go
ahead and post it
uh this week so we can promote it and
try to get some more peeps in there as
well
so sure yeah it's it's uh this saturday
at eight o'clock
uh i'll send uh i guess i'll post the
link
and then uh yeah and it's uh it's
it's free and it'll be fun yeah and i'll
take uh
for those of you listening on the
podcast or watching on youtube i'll
paste it in the show description as well
so you can jump in and that will be
saturday october
10th yes at 8 pm eastern correct
correct beautiful awesome so yeah
that'll be good
that'll be a good kind of um benchmark
in this journey we're tracking as well
so if you've been enjoying hearing steve
talk about the album definitely tune in
to that zoom
show and see it in action see those
sticky notes
in action uh that's gonna be so cool um
is there is there anything else before
we get out of here steve
no that that's uh that's it thank you so
much joel i appreciate it
beautiful hey man i appreciate you and
all all you're doing you're helping a
lot of comics here
likewise so let's
um thank you everyone that tuned in as
well people are loving it
giving applause and thumbs up and love
i love it so um that is it
hot breath the verse this has been our
second
installment of the steve rogers
chronicles we're gonna keep
documenting his journey into the album
so if you want to be a part of it
definitely join his zoom show this
saturday and definitely join our
facebook group it's free
we're doing feedback mics and daily
writing clubs and a bunch of other fun
stuff in there
so you definitely want to tune into that
and um
steve thank you amanda saying this is
great stuff
uh she loved it thanks steve and joel
definitely be watching your zoom show
yeah very nice everyone thank you
very nice holly saying thanks guys well
let's give
steve a round of applause go forth hop
breath the verse
subscribe to the youtube join the
facebook group
and we will see you on the next hot
breath podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you